To solve climate change, we need to get rid of every area of emission.
People think a lot about electricity and transportation,...
...but a lot less about buildings.
The challenge is not just how we build new buildings,...
...but what we do with all the buildings we have now.
So, one great innovation in this space is about windows.
Today's windows let the heat come in or the heat go out.
You have to run your heater during the winter a lot more.
It costs you money.
It's bad for climate change.
Well, so what Luxwall did,...
...as they said, can we make a window...
...that has a couple of layers of vacuum in there...
...that block the heat and so your house stays warm with far, far less energy?
Another company, AeroSeal,...
...has a solution for the problem of buildings leaking energy.
Other than through windows, the walls and ducts of your house...
...have a lot of leaks, little cracks that the air is flowing in and out of.
And again, that raises your heating bill,...
...which is bad for climate change.
Their very clever solution is they simply take polymer,...
...very sticky, special polymer, and they literally blow it.
And so it finds those cracks...
...and it kind of sticks to the edge of the cracks and creates a seal.
So, these are two innovations...
...that are dealing with the toughest part of building emissions...
...taking existing buildings, saving you money,...
...and reducing the climate burden.